Transcriber: Bashar Al-Thawabta
المدقّق: Mujtaba bakhet
(موسيقى المقدمة)
انا اسمى بشرى
عمري 12 سنة
واولى اعدادي
انا واطفال كثير مثلي
في عقولنا الكثير من التساؤلات
نبحث لها عن اجابة
مثل
لماذا في كائنات بتعيش بالبحر
وغيرها يعيش بالبر
لماذا لا نقدر العيش على كوكب اخر
غير كوكب الارض؟
لماذا اللبان (العلكة) مطاطي بهذا الشكل؟
لماذا الماء سر الحياة؟
وغيرها الكثير من الاسئلة التي تخطر
على ادمغتنا
وجدت مبادرة
تشجع الاطفال الى الوصول الى الاجابات
التي هم يطمحوا لمعرفة اجابتها بانفسهم
اولا، نكتب الكثير من الاسئلة
ونختار منهم اكثر سؤال نحن مهتمين به كثيرا
او لدينا فضول اليه
بدها نأخذ سؤالنا
الى رحلة بحث عبر الانترنت او الكتب
والخبراء
في الموضوع
ثم بعدها
بعدما نجد الاجابة التي نريدها
نؤلف قصة
تقدر توصل المعلومة للاطفال
بطريقة سهلة وبسيطة
عشان نقدر نفيد بعضنا بالقصص
وبعدما نكتب القصص
يختارو بعض من القصص
من القصص التي كتبوها ثم ينشروها
في تطبيق قراءة للاطفال
وبعضها يتم نشرها في نعرض الكتاب
لكي يشجعو الاطفال على انهم
يقمومو بكتابة قصص مفيدة
وانا كان عندي تساؤل عن السلاحف المائية
والسلاحف البرية
ولماذا السحلفاة البرية لا تقدر على
النزول في الماء؟
ما الذي سوف يحدث اذا نزلت الماء؟
وكتبت قصة لها
وسمتيها “الاستاذ زحلوف”
وقصتي نشرت في معرض الكتاب سنة 2022
وفي الموسم الذي يليه
كان عندي تساؤل عن اللبان لماذا مطاطي
وما مكوناته؟
وكيف يصنع؟
وبعد رحلة بحث، عرفت كل المعلومات عن اللبان
وكتبت قصة عنها وسميتها “رحلة علكة”
ونشرت قصتي في تطيبق “ابجز”
الرحلة كانت ممتعة مثيرة جدا
وبالنسة لي هذا امر مفيد جدا ان تبحث
عن اجابات لاسئلتك بنفسك
واقول لجميع الاطفال ان يبحثو عن اسئلتهم
في الكتب او الانترنت
في المصادر الموثوق منها او يستعينو بخبير
بالعلم كن فضوليا واكثر السؤال
كن فضوليا واطلق الخيال
(تصفيق)
(موسيقى)